can you explain to me one more time why  you wrote this book and why it's so  important to your legacy i think there  are three phases in one's life  the first phase is you're dependent on  others in your learning  and you graduate then you go in the  second phase of your life  and increasingly people are dependent on  you and you're working and you're trying  to be successful  i'm in transition from the end of that  phase to the next phase of my life and  the most important thing for me  is to help other people be successful i  learned along the way  certain things that helped me be  successful so whatever success i've had  has not been because of me  it's because of principles that i learn  along the way but you know you have the  collection kind of late in life and you  want to pass so i wanted to pass those  along